filipino fishermen here say
these are their most trying times danny
marasigan
is worried about his future it's really
sad
if the volcano explodes again where do
we go
there are no jobs anywhere anymore
last year's volcanic eruption coupled by
the coronavirus pandemic
have almost decimated the fishing
industry here
in a concealed municipality south of the
capital
manila it had been showing signs of
recovery over the past few months
but last thursday's volcanic activity is
threatening livelihoods
once again people here say they are
grateful they are able to work
many of them had to borrow money to
start over again and they remain
deep in debt they say they can't afford
another closure
the volcano spewed toxic black plumes
on thursday afternoon prompting the
local government to move
people living within the seven kilometer
danger zone
more than fourteen thousand have been
taken to temporary shelters
many of whom are dependent on fishing
for their livelihood
an hour away in talisai a popular
tourist destination
casil de guevara is doing all she can to
keep her three-year-old cafe
afloat we were really in the red
it's been tough what keeps me going i
have a responsibility to my staff
and also i just like to cook i like i
just like to
to serve people many businesses here
have closed
but there are those who remain defiant
and hopeful
that better days will come once again
jamilah linda al-jazeera talisai
batangas province
northern philippines